welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the teaser trailer for Westworld
season 3 has just dropped and already
the show looks like a wild departure
from the Western world that we saw in
the first two parts of the show
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the 3rd season as well as what we
can take from its trailer this is full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
fully through the first and second
season yet then I highly recommend that
you turn off now with that out the way I
just want to give a huge thank you per
click in this video I hope you enjoy it
and now sit back relax and let's get
into my West world season 3 breakdown
the first trailer reveals big changes to
the set up of West world with the season
seemingly following an unnamed
construction worker slash thief played
by none other than Aaron Paul just in
the same way that the synthetics and
hosts in the first season seemed to be
living life in a loop Paul's character
too seems unhappy with the day-to-day
existence and the monotony of it he
states that he feels betrayed by
promises that were never fulfilled and
from this we can guess that he was
originally supposed to have an easy life
due to the hosts doing most of the work
in society but this all came apart after
the events of season 2 in the trailer
Paul's character meets Dolores and it
hints that this is the something real
that he's been searching for Dolores is
sprinkled throughout the trailer and
she's back in her usual body those who
remember the end of the second season
will recall that Delores escaped using a
host that was identical to Charlotte
played by Tessa Thompson and at Arnold's
how she recreated her old body as Paul's
character is a thief there is a
possibility that Dolores could ask him
to break back into the park and steal
something for her which could
potentially be other hosts as she was
only able to smuggle out five though
Dolores currently has five pills with
her which as we know from season two our
hosts these characters will no doubt
likely be carryovers from the first two
seasons though we can rule out james
marsden as he managed to escape to the
paradise i can imagine she will recruit
paul to go back and get more and with
them wage
on the humans juxtaposing this is
Bernard who at the end of season 2 came
to the conclusion that there is hope for
Humanity and that we can be better if
given the opportunity
season 3 looks set to have Paul choose
between the sides but as always things
probably won't be that black-and-white
when discussing the season showrunner
Lisa joy stated it's going to be a whole
new world this series is about
reinvention and scope the first season
was a more intimate look at the park
from within the loops in the second
season the hosts broke out their loops
and were able to explore more of the
park in the third season they've broken
out of the park itself
we're in terra incognita from the
beginning when Jonah and I were thinking
about the series as far back as the
pilot we knew we wanted to explore other
worlds in the park and we also knew the
one world we would start to see little
glimpses up throughout the first two
seasons was the real world and that we
would get there eventually and when we
did it would be a whole new experience
so there's lots of things to look
forward to including many new mistakes
in addition to Paul's season three also
sets to add a whole new host of
characters excuse the pun with vincent
cassell joining the series as a villain
whilst little is known about the
character the actor has done some
phenomenal parts in Black Swan and
irreversible and he's a great addition
to the cast and finally the release date
whilst we don't know for definite when
the season will be released having only
20/20 as its date I can imagine that HBO
will want to take over the Game of
Thrones slot and thus we will see arrive
around the end of April or start of May
a massively excited for the new show and
I can't wait to see what happens when it
drops obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on season 3 of Westworld and if
you're looking forward to it comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
the ending of Game of Thrones would you
be linked at the end you've also just
launched a merge section on the channel
so if you want to support the show and
get something back from it make sure you
click the boxes in the links below
as we massively appreciate it
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]